alright guys bangbang I have the one and
only Dan Primack here tons to go over
thanks for jumping on and doing this
thanks for uh me let's start first just
your background and kind of what you're
doing at Axios now and then we'll get
into the fun stuff sure I think my Texas
business owner although that's probably
a misnomer that's kind of when I joined
they asked me what my title should be
and I made that up it was like six of us
at the time so it's still there I do a
couple things newsletter called the pro
rata newsletter which you get signups
just calm which covers venture capital
and private equity and mergers
acquisitions etc I do a daily podcast
also in the pro rata podcast which is a
little bit more generalist and the
intersection of politics tech and
business those main jobs what would you
do before next yes I was a fortunate for
about six six years I want to say both
doing a newsletter there and also as a
columnist in the magazine and then in
Thomson Reuters before that for about
decade or something got in Boston about
20 miles west of Boston we have trees
it's delightful as we were talking
before the podcast I got a he's head on
he's got a Celtics hat on but nobody's
doing [ __ ] so it's all good alright
let's dig into of the stimulus so
basically there's a financial crisis
happening there's tons of debate on how
bad it is but obviously big enough for
the stimulus package to get approved and
ultimately get kind of doled out here
maybe just walk us through it what
actually is in the stimulus both for
corporations and small businesses sure
so there's a ton in the stimulus as you
might imagine a two trillion dollar
package it just for some context I think
I'm speaking of school they're a little
tarp which was the thing that came after
the financial crisis in oh nine at least
the initial piece of tarp was I think
like 750 billion dollars so this is more
than twice what that was that took like
a month to put together and it failed a
few times of Congress this took about a
week so and we're already talking about
another one so just to give context for
the scope so there's a couple main
things here the one most people have
probably heard of is the checks that you
me and everybody else in theory will get
on these checks that could be you know
up to twelve hundred dollars per family
or per person depends on on your
personal income etc but there's
basically gonna be checks that are
mailed to every American taxpayer even
more if you have kids there's that
sitting in there that's a big piece of
there is kind of what they would call
unemployment on steroids so usually when
you get unemployment insurance if you
lose your job you get a percentage of
what you were making before this will
get people much closer to par in some
cases too far in some cases for very low
income people above par what they were
making before they got laid off um then
on the corporate side there's a few
things there's some industry specific
bailouts particularly for travel
hospitality airlines etc there is a big
corporate loan package which has not
been defined yet we're kind of waiting
for we're still waiting for guidance
through Treasury about what that's going
to be and then there's thing I think
we're mostly going to talk about today
which is the small business loan program
which is about three hundred and fifty
billion dollars on there called PPP
loans or payroll protection program
loans and the basic ideas these are for
companies that have fewer than 500
employees the loans can be for up to ten
million dollars and they base it on a
percentage of your payroll and for what
it's worth you do the calculation on
your payroll but anyone who makes over a
hundred thousand dollars their first
hundred thousand dollars is all that
counts so when you're doing the math if
you know if you have an employee that
makes half a million bucks as far as the
government's concerned they make
$100,000 for that calculation and again
and the point of this is to keep people
on the payroll
the proceeds are supposed to go towards
again keeping employees on and also
things like paying the rent utilities
etc they are technically forgivable
loans which means you don't necessarily
have to pay them back and they're
getting issued through private banks so
what you don't apply to the government
for it you apply to a bank for it and
then the bank is basically being backed
stopped by the federal government
originally Treasury an SBA but as just
announced today it now looks like the
Federal Reserve is gonna be backstop got
it let's first talk about kind of who's
the intended target of this because I
think that'll lead into you know the
further discussion and venture capital
private equity companies but my
understanding is this is mainly like
well most people would think of his
achill Main Street business will find
her employees or less that accurate I
think that's mainly aimed at again I
mean this is why we'll get into it the
goal is to keep people enjoyed I mean
that's the main goal of this is keep
people employed which is why there is
going there's another kind of 500
billion dollars set aside for larger
companies five hundred people plus but
yeah this is for five hundred and under
so yeah
mom-and-pops but 500 employees a lot
right there's no mom-and-pop with 450
people sitting at it so it's a little
wider range but I think when you look at
the averages that came out after the
first or second day of the program yeah
you were you weren't talking about those
maximum $10,000,000 loans very often
they were mostly smaller organizations
yeah and then the process for getting
the loans I think is kind of come under
scrutiny mainly because again to your
point this has been very rushed both
because it needs to be but also just the
way that is put together and right now
what if I'm a small business owner I go
to a bank I actually apply on day one at
least there were some banks who said
we're not gonna participate for various
reasons there are some banks you said
will participate but only for a certain
subset of clients and some banks you
said anyone and everyone come on in and
we'll help you out what's that look like
and kind of what's driving that it's
really really messy and in part because
the program that was announced was gonna
start last Friday Treasury secretary
munitions said starting Friday morning
this program is gonna be open well not
every bank was ready to go on Friday
morning a lot of in part and it wasn't
just the banks it's not cuz the bank's
weren't well organized the guidance from
Treasury didn't come out until Thursday
night so you're saying to banks you're
about to originate possibly tens of
thousands of loans tomorrow and at about
8:30 p.m. the night before it will give
you what all the rules are and by the
way remember these banks like you and me
and so many others most their bankers
are working from home also so they've
got the added you know difficulties it
and just think of anytime you've gotten
a loan business loan a mortgage or car
loan think of all the hoops and all the
paperwork you've gone through and now
you're asking these banks to process
thousands of these you know very very
quickly um so it was complicated Bank of
America was a good example so they were
kind of the first big bank to really
come online with us on Friday morning
but they announced that you had to have
two things you had to have an existing
business account with them and then you
had to either have also gotten a loan
from them at some point or had a
corporate credit card with that if you
didn't satisfy both of those things you
were out of luck Wells Fargo said you'd
have to be an existing customer and then
two days later said you have to be an
existing customer and have fewer than 50
employees and what this ultimately did
was if you were somebody who wanted a
PPP loan if you were legitimately a
restaurant hardware store whatever who
legitimately deserved one it almost
started
feel like if you pick the wrong Bank
five years ago when you open your
business you were screwed and in what a
random you know luck of the draw Feng
Menace
yeah so I think a lot of people have
heard this and like the conspiracy
theorist Amelia run to like oh the banks
are screwing us right I actually think
it's probably more about risk management
on the bank side any insight into like
why Bank of America says hey you have to
have the business account plus a credit
card or taking a loan before which they
started which they started to back off
of a little bit when they got prison
yeah look part of it as you say is risk
management part of it is also processing
right if you're an existing customer
whether it's a PA or Chase or anybody
else they technically do know more about
you on day one right they just do they
have got a lot of your records on hand
so they can process those quicker and
because there was gonna be such a rush
here there there is a business argument
to be made if you're if you know you're
gonna get flooded with these things the
thing you really don't want to do is
start taking on new clients and have
your existing clients left out and let
that look old you know what you know
they're your clients you can't do that -
yeah and so I guess let's just you know
kind of assume that the processing
component it's gonna get solved right
the banks will get online
cuz someone says also technical I think
I set up a website they got to take
intake where do you store that database
how do you make sure that it's secure
all that kind of stuffs gotta get set up
but once we get past that then this
brings into question okay
who's intended for and who also should
be available and this is where you and I
start to go back and forth on Twitter of
Main Street business small business five
her employees are less pretty
understandable and I could show you five
businesses if I could pick those three
match those two don't write that that's
pretty clear but then you get into what
about venture businesses right so
venture capital backed businesses that
have five hundred employees or less are
those part of this private equity then
stuff up and says well wait for a second
like what about our companies you kind
of spread out from like that core
demographic and we're target help me
understand like where does that late
right from my where it lays right now is
complicated so private equity is
privately backed companies so long as
when we think of private equity in this
contest we're talking about private
equity owned right so the private equity
firm controls the company has 51% or
more of the voting stock say they're out
of this they're they're they're they
they are out of luck they know they're
out of luck
the venture backed ones are more
complicated and again we're talking
about venture backed companies that you
know you know a firm a has
10% from B as 10% something like that uh
the problem here is something called the
affiliation and what the affiliation
rule says is if I am it and if you and I
both run venture-backed companies and we
have the same VC firm we might each only
have a hundred employees but as far as
the Small Business Association is
concerned we're both controlled by a
venture capital firm how many employees
do they indirectly have throughout their
entire portfolio so suddenly my fifty or
a hundred person business and yours
actually as far as the government's
concerned might have three thousand
employees and suddenly we don't qualify
because we don't have five hundred or
less for this program there has been a
push a bipartisan push by Nancy Pelosi
ROH Khanna on the left Kevin McCarthy on
the right to change this at least for
venture-backed startups um
they there were new rules that came out
I want to say on Friday night or
Saturday night that were supposed to
address this they didn't completely
because they didn't seem to understand
how basically how venture capital
charter stock stock charters work for
example the fact that the somebody and
this is really in the weeds but if I'm a
series B investor I technically have
veto rights maybe over a dividend or
something like that so McCarthy's people
told me last night that they are trying
to get additional guidance so that
venture-backed startups of under 500
employees can qualify for these and can
legitimately and there and and what and
the problem of course is it's the banks
that would be the ones holding the ball
so what they need to do they need to say
to the banks don't worry about it the
affiliation rules don't count because if
I'm a banker I can't take a venture back
company today and give them a PPP loan
and then have the federal government
come to me seven months later and say
actually you shouldn't given them that
loan it's not guaranteed anymore the
banks just can't do that they shouldn't
do that it's too much risk particularly
not a low interest rate for sure and
then how does this fit in with the
private equity folks like or the private
equity owned businesses is there talk
about them getting access to either this
three hundred fifty billion dollars a
stimulus or maybe in another package
that comes for them or they kind of just
out of luck it's interesting the ones
that are 500 employees or more might be
okay because there is this other there's
this other pot of money this 500 billion
dollars which by the way it might be
where Boeing and others get money from
but it's there they're calling this a
midsize lending package but again we
don't have details on that but it is the
private equity backed come
that are smaller than 500 and it's
interesting when we think private equity
we think you know KKR and Blackstone and
TPG and these huge firms that buy
brand-name companies that we've all
heard but there is an enormous amount of
private equity particularly in the
Midwest if I small manufacturing
companies small industrial companies
separate maybe with like 40 50 employees
those companies are out of luck in terms
of this yeah and I guess this really is
kind of the thought process here of this
isn't a bailout right so you kind of
kind of put bailouts on one side these
are loans you described earlier the I'll
look forgivable loans so it's gonna
happen yeah my question on what terms do
I not have to pay it back versus I would
have to pay it back if I get actually
some of the stimulus I think I don't
want to speak and be too wrong on this I
think in general so long as you meet the
requirements in terms of maintenance of
payroll I so I think it's like 90
percent and again don't look at this up
don't trust me on this and then go apply
for a loan but if you maintain something
like 90 percent of your employee base
then you then it is considered
forgivable I think you have to be able
to prove need but it's interesting when
you look at the application documents
and not bank specific ones the the
recommendation from Treasury and SBA
it's really really vague what you have
to say it doesn't say you need this
money to maintain operations which would
be okay wait a minute to keep my 50
employees and then my what no it just
says to support operations well in
theory any money to any business
supports operations give ten million
dollars to goldman sachs that'll support
operations of course it will now do they
need it no but would it support
operations so there's pretty big
question you know that word support is
doing a lot of work in that application
and I think from a technical perspective
it opens up a lot of businesses that
might not you know aren't gonna go under
without the money to justifiably say you
know what our revenue went down a little
bit um maybe we weren't able to hire as
fast or you know lost the customer or
whatever or worried about that in the
future we qualify yeah is that an
intentional use of the word support do
you think or is that just something kind
of hey it was put together quickly and
could have been clarified better I think
the purpose of this was to keep as many
people on payrolls as humanly possible
as fast as possible and
to me and now you and I might disagree
about this but I so I think they wanted
to cast as wide a net as they possibly
could because I think as far as the
federal government is concerned the
difference between somebody who loses
their job on Main Street or on Sand Hill
Road is largely irrelevant to them they
need people to keep their jobs period
yeah that make sense and I guess part of
this too then comes down to if you go to
the corporates I like the bailout piece
right that there's this entire
conversation around is the bailout to
save the company or is it to save the
job right and I think your your take is
actually what a lot of the stimulus is
doing is just trying to save jobs it
doesn't really care so much about the
companies almost I don't want to say
it's a indifferent to the survival of
the company it's more so trying to save
jobs that generally well this particular
the PPP I mean it's literally payroll
protection program I mean it's
explicitly about jobs absolutely yes got
it and so on the bailout side part of
what it seems like is you get these
private equity investors who are saying
wait a minute hold on our guys aren't
available for this why don't we get it
and my position was well listen you guys
got tons of dry powder you're sitting
there if you believe in the company put
money in right and this extends all the
way even to the corporates where whether
its United or Boeing or whoever it's
like look at some point there's a price
for investors we'll put in debt or
equity now it may be a dislocation and
you know what me as an investor or you
as an investor believes the value of the
company is first of all the executives
believe it's worth but at some point
there's a market and it feels like
people are just kind of running to the
government I wrote earlier this week
about or last week about they're like
the idiot in the room they'll give the
most favorable terms that you couldn't
get from the private market do you agree
with that disagree with that kind of how
do you see that play out i I think I
agree with it I think it actually
reflects some of the worst the venture
capital and private equity but here's
the way I look at it if your venture
capital of private equity and you've got
a business that is actually struggling
you know maybe it's retailer and they've
had shut stores a restaurant chain or
whatever else it is um they're looking
at this right now and saying the most
financially prudent thing for us to do
is to lay people off if we have a
retailer and we've had to close the
stores it does us no good from a fiscal
perspective just to keep the people on
payroll now
if we want to keep the people on payroll
we have a choice if we're gonna do it
and assuming again we're not a wildly
profitable company with you know
billions of dollars or hundreds of
millions dollars in bank which few of
these companies have um what in
particularly if their private equity
back they probably got debt interest
payments that you have to keep meeting
the banks have not given anyone a break
on that um so the private equity funds
gonna say okay we're probably gonna lay
people off because we're not gonna go to
our investors the pension funds the
endowments the you know the sovereign
wealth funds or whatever and say yeah
we're doing a call down we need 20
million dollars for company X and we're
not doing it to grow the business we're
just doing it to pay people who aren't
actually working right now it's gonna be
a written to be honest a you could
actually get sued for that in theory but
another piece of this is remembered
there investors are struggling also in a
lot of cases and having liquidity
problems cuz they had a public market
portfolio that's been slashed by 30
percent in the past three weeks so the
last thing date and and you wouldn't be
talking about 20 million for ten million
for one portfolio company you might be
saying to the your investor yeah we're
gonna do about 50 capital calls today
which is just an incredible amount so in
their view in the way when I talk to
them is we want the money from the
government today to keep people on the
payroll if we have to put money in at
some point that's going to be to keep
the actual entity afloat so that when
all of this some day ends there will
still be an entity in a building for
them to return to I I am very
understanding of the argument they've
got money they should invest I
definitely am understanding the argument
some of these partners should be pulling
money out of their own pockets I think
that's definitely true you've seen in a
few cases like Leonard green a buyout
firm in LA but again if the point of
this is to keep people employed if you
want to say you know what venture
capital firms private equity firms
you're behaving badly fine
doesn't change the fact someone's gonna
lose their job yeah I think it's a
really important distinction cuz you're
basically drawing the line between
wisdom and optimizing for what the
government is optimizing for safe jobs
the private equity investor is
optimizing for return on investment and
save the company right and actually
those two things are in some cases
actually opposite of what you would do
from an action perspective when you fire
everyone the other you keep everyone and
so it's trying to understand how do you
you know basically get people to do the
right thing and keeping the jobs which
is against kind of the capitalistic view
of safety company at all
it is and look they I mean there was a
solution to this and we'll see maybe on
the bigger loan package was we haven't
seen the rules yet a solution would have
been of course taking some sort of
equity in the companies but would the
PPP program is still pretty small I mean
again you know if you're a 400 person
private equity backed company again the
maximum loan is 10 million bucks if 10
million dollars is the different swings
you know living and dying that it's
probably not the case this is still for
mostly for small businesses and the
federal government I just from a
logistics standpoint does not want
equity in you know 80,000 small
businesses across America yeah and so I
guess then that brings the question of
like is there concern around like the
extremists would say hey this is
nationalizing large corporations right
whether it's United Boeing yeah those
types of companies but at the other side
would be well actually the taxpayer
should have all of the exposure to the
benefit of their capital being used
right so whether it's debt with warrants
whatever kinda how does that playing out
or what investor saying they're like I'm
partial to that I think the government
should get equity if you're giving
billions of dollars to a big corporation
that should damn well get equity then
the upside shouldn't all be for the
shareholders ah you know it's
interesting a Boeing CEO and God you
know every day now is like a lifetime in
this world but I want to say this like
three weeks ago before the cares Act was
passed Boeing CEO got asked about this
he said oh if their equity strings
attached we're just not going to take it
into money we have all these better
options he never explained what any of
the better options were we asked Boeing
repeatedly no one could quite answer
that question it seems if you had better
options he would take them interruptions
like if I have a better option that's
what I usually take why wouldn't I it's
a better option so like I look at in the
government sure the government had
equity stay excited you know through
tarp it had equity stakes in the auto
bailout in certain cases in GM and yeah
it's an activist investor asked anybody
at GM if the government was a passive or
active investor was an active investor
it should have been it was a lot of
money was a lot of taxpayer money it
ended up making people money back you
know the the federal government
ultimately made money on the financial
bailouts of o.9 on the on the auto
bailouts um so it's not a bad yeah but I
of course there should be equity for the
big chests why shouldn't there be it
shouldn't all be private shareholders
who benefit from this yeah and what
happened to the equity in those cases so
I couldn't GM's case or whatever do they
basically hold the equity until there's
like debt paid back and then they saw
the equity or how does that
yeah they ultimately decide to sell it
you know every situation is different
you know you what you really want is the
underlying entity to be stable but yeah
eventually they sell it and they sell it
you know either on the open market
theoretically you could sell back to the
company hell in theory itself to a
private equity firm but yeah they
eventually sold it and they were very
public about it they did it in pieces
etcetera but yeah at once
once the company is stable and there is
a market for it again the government
sells it hopefully to profit yeah and I
guess really this then brings a question
of like okay we get the first kind of
wave of stimulus two trillion dollars
I'm assuming that there's gonna have to
be more over time it's soon like they're
already closed has already got a plan
out the cares Act - it's coming it's
coming quickly because almost everybody
agrees that what was in the first one
wasn't enough money because there's also
all sorts of like in the first one there
was you know there was hospital bailout
money which is desperately needed there
is going to be more of that needed
states and municipalities there was
money for them there's gonna have to be
tons more of that think about if you're
a municipality that makes most of your
money off of sales and tourism taxes or
not most but a huge amount of your money
off sales and tourism taxes your city's
been shut down for three weeks but
you're still paying your teachers your
cops your firemen your sanitation
workers and everybody the same out what
and you and you have to balance your
budget usually legally if you're a
municipality or state and you have bonds
that are due what are you gonna do about
that you're going to need a bailout and
only one entity in America can print
money the the metric I saw or the
article was talking with the MTA how the
MTA basically saying like locally
nobody's right in some way it's down 90
percent right if we have 90 percent drop
in ridership how the hell we're gonna
pay the bonds and by the way for
airports as well airports as well oh
really okay yeah it works out bonds have
built them and they collect that you
know when you get your airline ticket
from JetBlue or United whatever part of
what you're paying for is actually the
operations the airport there's a fee in
there those fees are obviously down 80
percent got it and what are you hearing
from my private equity investors venture
capitalists in terms of how does this
change the landscape of just business
investing in general what I mean by that
is you know there's obvious stuff hey
people gonna start asking is your
company pandemic proof rather than
recession proof type stuff right but
actually does this make people more
gun-shy or people getting you know kind
of salivating and say hey we're gonna
get more aggressive here we think
there's gonna be some cheap buys but
what do you see from from a strategy
standpoint across different
on the venture capital side on the
early-stage side I haven't seen all that
much of a change
um yeah obviously the the mechanics of
doing things for different people aren't
topping on planes and hanging out it you
know oh I see networking parties anymore
so the mechanics change but there's
actually been a pretty decent amount of
VC activity in the last few weeks
admittedly not as much as there was
before this um decent amount
particularly on the biotech side I so
you know cuz if you're a pre-revenue
company you haven't necessarily been
affected yet cuz you who aren't selling
anything to start with a bunch of the
later stage venture deals have blown up
there's no doubt about that over pricing
because no one really knows what the
what anything is worth now um then on
the mound the by the buyouts have
largely slowed down there's some they're
still getting done
new ones are pretty rare for two reasons
one is the pricing issue you know what
is this thing worth and then B there's a
debt issue there's a question of whether
you can issue whether you can issue new
junk bonds or new high-yield bonds which
is usually what private equity deals get
done with there's been a lot of these
junk bond funds raised in the last
couple weeks but very little new
issuance because remember the banks have
to issue it and then they usually
syndicated out and find other buyers and
they are not at all convinced yeah and I
guess really what ends up happening is
if all of the over leverage in the
private equity companies is just
applying more pressure to them getting
the relief they need because you know if
you look so these retail restaurants for
somebody's you've made I mean we're
talking revenue going 2-0 it's not like
hey it's down 30% just because people
are going out a little less zero where
do you get the money to pay you know two
or three months of your debt payment you
know these are huge issues because you
know it's certain companies just happen
to be managed very very well and happen
to have a massive rainy day fund or more
likely we're really lucky when they
raised right they raised money in
January and thank God they raise money
in January and weren't planning to do it
at April nobody it's an enormous problem
you know in the financial crisis the
leverage the the private equity backed
deals actually survive most of them
survive there were some big bankruptcies
but a lot of them survived because what
the banks said was okay look almost none
of you can make your debt payments so we
have a choice either we can assume the
companies which we don't really want to
do because among other things we don't
have any internal way to manage company
X or Y or what we'll do is what they
started calling amend and extend which
is okay your debt payment was due in
April it's now gonna be due next April
we're gonna add a point or half a point
interest onto it but we're basically to
push you off and and in theory you could
do that again this time except that this
time you have get payments from
everybody do it once and everybody wants
to extend municipalities want to every
corporate does investment-grade and junk
bond individuals who have home mortgage
kids who have car payments the entire
system there's so much pressure on it on
the lender side they can't amend and
extend everybody and if they did in
theory if they did well you'd end up is
that liquidity crunch that we were all
freaked out about 2009 where banks just
stopped lending in this case would you
be justified because they have no money
because no one's making the interest
payments which is then you know rolls
back out into the economy yeah what do
you see me yeah what are you seeing on
the pension side with like the LPS right
so you kind of you got the companies you
get the investors and then you go all
the way back out to the LPS a lot of
them are left especially public pensions
holding kind of this corporate debt or
kind of credit issues but what are you
seeing on that front we're seeing
something called the denominator effect
which we last saw 2009 and what the
denominator effect basically if you're a
corporate pension or public pension your
allocations say to venture capital is
maybe 5% and but that 5% number in terms
of real dollars it's 5% of the overall
assets of the pension fund so if the
pension fund is doing really well in the
stock market that 5% means more actual
dollars going to venture capital if your
stock market portfolio has gone [ __ ] as
it has now suddenly it's a lot less and
so you have a lot of pension funds that
thought they were under allocated three
months ago or three weeks ago who are
now very over allocated and what I'm
hearing from pensions and from
endowments particularly remember and
down that's also because they don't have
students physically in the dorms right
now and they've got their own financial
issues is that they are saying to to
investment firms look we can generally
still make capital calls if you have
them but in terms of new fund raise and
new fund commitments you better be best
of the best for us to be doing this this
is not the time to be raising a new fund
there have been a bunch of fund closings
announced recently but almost all of
those were commitments that were baked
in months or weeks ago yeah the the
endowment game is always so funny to me
a tweet the other day I said I think
we're gonna see a lot of exposure of
universities basically their asset
management firms would just schools
right for the tax benefit but we'll see
how many of them actually dip into the
endowment and you know part of the
endowments there to rainy day fund type
stuff and
there's been a number of schools now
that have laid off really I think
they're laying off vendors right or kind
of severing ties with vendors who then
lay off the cafeteria staff or
maintenance staff etc but you hope to
see again going back to are you
optimizing for kind of your P&L at the
school or are you optimizing for saving
jobs if they want to say the jobs then
they can kind of dip into that they also
have huge question marks right like a
lot of these schools they make a lot a
lot of them not all of them a lot that
make a lot of money in the summer off
the summer programs which unlike during
the regular year where so many people
are on scholarship
those summer programs people generally
not exclusively aren't paying for them
in particularly people from other
countries like China are coming in and
paying for them there they're possibly
facing none of that revenue and there
are look there's the legitimate
questions if they're opening the doors
again in September and if they don't
what exactly does that mean for them and
by the way are they going to be opening
the door for people from China to come
in students oh yeah I don't know do you
think this changes the way that people
view kind of higher education like the
whole idea of it I saw a couple tweets
flying around like hey I'm paying fifty
thousand dollars for my kid to sit at
home on zoom' right I mean look I don't
think anyone would argue that you get a
better class experience in person if
it's a decent school and there's certain
things you can't do at home right if
you're a biology major a chemistry major
you're you can learn things you can't do
what you could do and you can't have the
same discussions I mean look there are
there is tell learning that's a thing
and just like we can work remotely and a
lot of people do but there is an
argument that to be made that there is a
difference still between a meeting and
zoom and a meeting face to face that
different things happen different you
know you have conversations more
organically or different you know in a
video conversation or on a phone call or
in person I think you just do as a
reporter I can tell you if I sit down
with someone for 30 minutes in a coffee
shop I almost always get more out of
that than 30 minutes on the phone or
thirty minutes on a video conference you
just do
I think that'll come true in schools 2
plus is you and I both know you know as
far as the students are concerned the
experience of college of being there is
a lot bigger than the classes yeah fit
fit at least 50% is the social side of
it at least
and then obviously a Silverlake they've
made a bunch of big moves recently both
the twitter deal and then they just
announced about a billion dollars and
everybody Airbnb what what already seen
on that front so they're interesting
because they're about to launch
fundraising with that
I just said don't raise money they're
going to apparently they're gonna try to
raise sixteen billion dollars for their
for their new general fund and they'll
get it probably to Silverlake is
interesting because they've had some
struggles
WME which is William Morris Endeavor
which also happens to own Ultimate
Fighting Championship and professional
bull riding interestingly which was
supposed to go public last year wasn't
able to just have to lay off a bunch of
people just thinking what they do they
represent actors and people in the
entertainment industry and there is no
entertainment production right now at
all you can't sign someone to a deal
when there's nothing to do so they're
having some struggles there but but
silver lakes looking I think at Airbnb
is a pretty good opportunity um you know
we don't yet know what the deal terms
are on this but I'm sure they got a
better deal than they could have five
months ago and Airbnb is obviously they
say they've got enough cash but
obviously as a company that could use
some extra liquidity and some extra
cushion given that their businesses
basically shut down yeah do you think
that silver like anything changes at
Twitter after they come in it's hard to
say I mean cuz because there's a
activist hedge fund Elliott that that's
also in there and helping drive the ship
they help bring so Silverlake into that
you know it's interesting you know
Elliott and Silver Lake both got into
Twitter before all hell broke loose so I
think like a lot of things asked me
again in six or eight months hopefully
when things are back to normal I I think
when I talk to investors on the private
and the public side they all basically
say that you know q1 and q2 of 2020 are
just written off you know
performance good performance bad it's
irrelevant we can take nothing from it
in terms of how this company's gonna
perform long term maybe outside of you
know an outlier like a zoom yeah for
sure
Carnival Cruise we just saw the the big
stake which would take their cruise
companies I mean I I don't have a
particular take on it except look I I'm
not a cruise person but like every time
there is any sort of you know you almost
know going onto a cruise ship you're
gonna get sick with something so if
there's gonna be a pandemic they're
gonna get you know even more sick it's a
it's a disaster I mean this is the worst
thing that could happen for a company
like them it's like amusement parks or
other tourist things except you know
when Disney decided to close they didn't
wrapped everybody inside a Thunder
Mountain for three weeks like they let
you leave it's awful look there is a
business there people love cruises I am
curious though you know when you talk
about
how the economy will eventually come
back and what will open what won't and
you know you know you're where as you
said Yankees hat
if the Yankees announced in three weeks
you know what opening day we're gonna
play a game how many people show up at
Yankee Stadium that goes you know
exponentially for a cruise line yeah the
the thing I saw was the Saudis took an
eight point two percent stake in
carnival and it's very interesting
because you get almost that the pricing
conversation comes into play right it's
like has it bottomed has it not you've
got some people who've got a ton of
capital sitting around the table and are
they gonna get excited early or they're
timing it correctly and that goes for
the soft banks of the world the Saudis
except you're kind of all around global
I think I think everybody's having to
make a guess on when all of this ends
right because in theory if you and I are
still stuck in our house in August it's
entirely possible to say that the Saudi
state goes to nothing and the company
like they're you know what do or care is
act to great there are only so many
federal bailouts you can do um and so
that's the bet right the bet is really a
timing bet on the virus as much to me as
much as it is on the companies and
they're trying time it out and saying
okay they might be able to start you
know putting ships out again in you know
make it up August July September they're
making that calculation I assume the
Saudis are but everyone's just guessing
nobody has a clue
you're just making your best-case
scenario you're seeing this in state
governments you know budgeting
committees are saying well best-case
scenario stores reopened in July first
worst-case scenario they don't schools
comeback schools don't come back yeah
the the ones that just caught my eye was
I think it's DC and Virginia both
announced stay at home orders till June
10th is kind of the current guidance and
you know it's pretty far away we're
talking you know seventy plus days away
or so it's pretty far away but I mean
the the the thing that would be worse
you could argue is if and this is why
trumps whole you know we're gonna reopen
things by Easter which is this weekend
this Sunday which is just nuts to think
that he was saying that a week ago is
you know the worst thing that would
happen would be that everything would
start reopening people would go out and
then we'd all have to go back into
lockdown because the the crisis of
confidence from that would be
extraordinary one thing though is we
still don't really have any sort of
answers on how we're gonna reopen things
because we haven't done the kind of
contact tracing that has is required
that was done in South Korea that was
done in Taiwan um it's unclear how we're
going to know when it is quote safe to
go
to work like you know I haven't gotten
sick yet maybe I have right maybe I was
asymptomatic but how is anyone going to
know how am I gonna know that is safe
for me to not get other people sick by
going into a store going to my kids
school any of that we haven't done any
of that stuff you know I I don't know
who I know or who I came into contact
with who has tested positive we don't
have enough testing to just test
everybody which would be the ideal thing
to do and then you could literally just
quarantine X percentage of people for 14
days and be done with it um we don't
have any of that in place yet we are so
far behind I I think June 10th is
optimistic yeah I don't think that June
10th everyone's gonna just walk back out
their door and go do what they were
doing before right it's just a lot of
people saying hey the world we're going
back to is gonna look different right
whatever that ends up being but then
that leads the conversation of how many
small businesses can actually survive
till June 10th without reven Wright just
it feels to me like we're talking
double-digit percentages of them that
don't come back after this absolutely
you know I was driving that through
Boston the other night and obviously
it's a weird city right now because it's
very very dark you know so many it was
like 8 p.m. so it's dark out but so many
restaurants storefronts and stuff work
yeah there were no lights on and it
occurred to me that when quote the world
comes back I'm gonna drive through those
same neighborhoods and what I'm gonna
see is I'm gonna see a bunch of lights
that are on but then a weird number that
are off instead of all being off almost
like it's 2:00 a.m. it's gonna be 8 p.m.
and a bunch will be on but a ton are
gonna be off you're going to see just
just yeah this weirdness it's almost
like when you're in a city that's got
like a bunch of abandoned buildings it's
going to be a bunch of abandoned
storefronts lots yeah yeah in New York
right now it's got to be 75 80 % in
storefronts or just off right there's
not operating at all and you know it's
bad when they've literally boarded up
like and I'm not talking about like the
Saks Fifth Avenue type stuff and I'm
talking about literally like the local
bar has boarded up their doors and they
just don't expect to come back for a
while and there's questions you know the
commercial landlords in this many of
whom are actually behaving pretty well I
am giving people deferments on rent or
even or even for giving rent but they're
paying they still have their mortgages
to pay and and so you could also a
building's go bankrupt you know in
theory when things come back it's
entirely possible that landlords are
gonna say you know to potentially new
tenants the new pizza shop we won't
you rent for the first three months yeah
they're gonna beg people to come in
because they're gonna have this problem
as well I think there's gonna be a lot
of giveaways at the beginning but
somebody gets screwed yeah somebody
always does yeah do you think that if
this lasts long enough we do see kind of
the full waterfall effect where you get
the businesses the investors are all you
know kind of turned upside down then you
do get the commercial real estate impact
all the way out to the banks and and
even could see some liquidity issues
with the banks that you were kind of
leaning to earlier I do I wish I didn't
I I see this is a really dark hole
I really do I see it and we're writing a
little bit about this in the next couple
days as I said earlier the municipal and
local government side you know it's one
thing for quote Detroit to go bankrupt
or you know 40 years ago New York to go
bankrupt and you say okay this is a
poorly managed city a poorly managed
county or town or they had a you know an
earthquake or something but we'll deal
with that because the state can backstop
it's not gonna let was town or city go
under but no state has ever dealt with
dozens of towns or cities and counties
going on during they don't have the
money to backstop them all and and what
happens then I do you have to lay off
all the teachers like what the back-up
plan for a school system was about the
plan for police and fire departments or
sanitation like this thing to me you
know the the comparison to the financial
crisis in the financial crisis we knew
in retro it's started we knew where the
source of the problem was we knew where
the original crack of the dam was so the
job was plug the hole in the dam and
then go clean up all the water that has
flooded everywhere and that wasn't easy
but you knew you could find it all in
this case to be honest in this case the
dam has been blown up there there are so
many cracks you can't even see the
concrete anymore and I I'm a bit
apocalyptic about this I don't quite see
outside of a treatment real soon or
vaccine real soon so treatment more
likely in vaccine best-case scenario
vaccine is early next year I I see this
being it's not even a domino effect it's
a bunch of kids playing Monopoly and one
gets pissed off and kicks over the table
and the dog eats some of the houses in
the hotels there's just nothing just all
blown out yeah do you think that we'll
see payoff to the pension funds we might
but again there comes the question is
the Fed's balance sheet truly limitless
like okay they're bailed out small
businesses they bailed out large
businesses they've already said they're
been
have hospitals and mate then they're
doing some bailouts of cities and towns
like at what point do we stop and at
what point does massive inflation begin
but our pension funds going to be
balanced absolutely public pension funds
transportation pension funds all of that
absolutely yeah yeah you you saw around
the corner so if we see the massive
bailouts all across the place and what
point of people question the currency
and they just say look you know the the
bread got more expensive you know from
last week to this week but you know I
don't think we're quite there yet but
this is the path to that world if we're
gonna go to that world right it is I
mean you know the only saving grace
potentially is in the financial crisis
the people looked at it and said well
it's possible the entire financial
system is gonna collapse and we don't
know what I'm what's under that and what
happens in this case everyone knows that
this will end which is different like
that the the source of this coronavirus
is going to be might be next year but
there will be a vaccine there will be a
treatment that curves will battened all
that stuff and so I mean you saw you
know we're taping this on what's today
Monday and the markets went up a lot
today that's the only saving grace is
that if there are enough long term
investors who decide that they believe
in these companies in this economy long
term or Silverlake sit and believe in
the Airbnb or Saudis who believe in
Carnaval that can get us through this
and independent specific than the
pension fund side and that their public
equity values just won't be absolutely
demolished and there will be money
they'll be able to sell stock that can
then pay the pensioners you get
dividends they'll pay the pensioners
yeah in some weird world it's almost
like the private investors are bailing
out the government by plugging some of
those holes you talked about right so
the government just have to step in and
print even more money to then go ahead
and stop holes themselves absolutely
look that's partially how the system is
supposed to work in terms of this stuff
the problem is there are these holes
that are not equity holes that are debt
holes and those people can come and buy
debt but it doesn't work the same way
yeah last question for you what's the
one thing that you're paying attention
to that either other people haven't
noticed yet or you think more people
should be paying attention to either a
cool story or just some kind of
structural issue that you see that
people aren't talking about I think it's
it's the future reputa on the venture
capital in the private equity side
reputation what you're doing now that
might not be viewed as in your best
short-term fiduciary interest but it
will it come in and pay you back in the
end um you know back in 2001 2002 after
the.com crash you saw a lot of venture
capital firms decided granted sometimes
their limited partners had to push them
to do this but they cut the size of
their funds so you know they had raised
five hundred million dollars in 1999 and
by 2001 they realized wait a minute we
can't reasonably invest this anymore cuz
valuations are now cut in half maybe the
sorts of companies we're investing in
don't exist anymore so we have a choice
we can either continue to collect the
fees off of this every year and get rich
or we can say to our limited partners
you know you committed fifty million
dollars we're cutting the fund in half
you're only on the hook for twenty five
and if you look back from that the for
the most part the funds that cut their
fun sizes all still exist and it's been
20 years the ones that didn't that were
really egregious about it are almost all
gone because they they they I mean you
know the limited partners were on the
hook they were contractually on the hook
they paid the money they had to pay and
these people now all live in good houses
but you know people remember people
remember if you act well are you act
badly in a crisis I think that's
definitely gonna be true for private
equity firms as well ultimately whether
you're a startup or you're a company
that's gonna be taking over you can
choose who is taking you over and you
can always just take the best price or
you can choose somebody who you think is
a good actor and I I do believe in karma
and I believe good actors are going to
be paid back in the end for the way they
act during this because this is an
unprecedented time and honestly most
venture capital firms most private
equity firms the partners themselves a
management companies themselves they
have a lot of money they can do a lot of
this bailout work themselves even though
it hurts yeah I think it's a great
message of just speak kind man just just
trying to do the right thing and you may
actually may not get it right but but I
think people understand kind of the
ethos and the intention behind a lot of
this work even if people don't get it
right exactly they still understand what
someone's trying to accomplish
absolutely great yeah we're can work at
people go find you on on the internet on
the interweb cast yeah on the interwebs
you can get the pro rata newsletter at
sign up Axios com pro access pro rata
podcast on iTunes and Spotify and all
those fun things and then on Twitter at
Dan Primack
that's Dan PR
I am ACK you're you're one of the most
well-connected people in tech and
Finance so I appreciate coming on and
share some of the insights I think
people enjoy us thanks for having me
appreciate